[Music]
let's go to lisa in milwaukee wiscanson
what's up lisa
hey how are you i'm so good how are you
good
um i have a little bit of drama to share
with you
oh sweet hey the last caller
was with somebody and his wife was with
somebody and then they hooked up and had
a kid so you got to beat that go
yeah hopefully it's not as bad but i
don't know
so my boyfriend is 36 years old and he
still lives with a roommate but his
roommate is his ex and i'm wondering how
do i move forward with him
[Laughter]
you may have just won this is awesome
you may have just you may have just
defeated
the last caller lisa
so you are dating a guy who's 38 how
long you have been together
um so we've only been together for six
months
and
do you love him
i do love him rose okay so you love him
and
there's just one little hang up is um
he lives with his ex-girlfriend still
yeah
why why does he do that why are you
putting up with that
um well okay so they've been together
like living together for years now like
seven years
and they're friends he says they're just
friends who thinks of her is just one of
the guys
that he can have sex with
but she has a boyfriend
okay
oh my gosh i want you to listen to the
last call
and then you can come back and just put
yourself right back into this call just
now
there's a 100 chance they're hooking up
a
hundred okay a thousand percent chance
and even if they weren't
the toxicity around this is so
disturbing
and what's most disturbing to me is that
you have settled for this how old are
you
i'm 29.
why
why has this been where you think this
is what this is the best i can do
i guess the problem is i should tell you
that i have borderline personality
disorder okay so and i have ptsd so i
just feel like i can't trust my
intuition anymore i don't know like if
they're hooking up if they're not like
i'm constantly fighting myself on if
they're not
um
you should find a new therapist number
one number two this isn't about what
they're doing
okay i i did that for some theater
because we're on the radio
what matters here is
you
think that you're defective or broken
borderline personality disorder is hard
right you know that you feel a lot right
you feel deeper than most people most of
the time
and those feelings and emotions are
they are powerful right
yeah tell me about your trauma
um
it's uh
sexual assault so
yeah i'm gonna start the crash
and here's
it's still really close to the surface
for you right yeah and there's a
boyfriend
yeah you did it to me so ugh i'm so so
sorry
so sorry
often when i hear when i hear the
situation about the drama
you have
you and life circumstances and by the
way that kind of trauma changes your
brain
it changes your shame cycle of shame
changes how you see yourself and your
self-worth and your value
you and i have never met and if you
would hear i wouldn't say anything for
the next five minutes i would ask your
permission if i could just give you a
hug and if you said yes i would hug you
for five minutes without saying a word
because i don't know if you can remember
a time
when somebody was with you
without wanting something from you
without wanting sex without wanting
connection without wanting needing you
to go do a thing for me
that someone was just with you because
of you do you remember that last time
um it's probably been a while right it's
been like seven years there you go
and i want you to know that you're worth
just being with
and you that trauma's real close to the
top and my guess is if you were honest
you and i talked for a while there's
probably some even more trauma back from
when you were younger
is that fair
yeah okay
i want you to heal from that trauma
before you get into another dating
relationship because you're going to
find yourself dating some guy that still
lives with his ex-girlfriend and says
nah dude everything's cool and you're
going to make yourself bananas because
you know it's not right
not that it's not right in the moral
sins it's not right from a value sense
you're worth more than that
and you know that he doesn't look at you
directly
and he'll say all the right things
because man he's got a great gig going
mm-hmm that's not about that it's about
you
yeah and if you have a a a therapist
that says no that's cool man
just keep loving him
dude i got a real problem with that
because that's about value
yeah that's true and when i tried to
talk to him about like i was accusing
him of that's something that we do um
with bpd sometimes like
we'll have
we'll be so afraid of being alone and
like we'll start these fights and then
like i accuse him of like sleeping with
her even if it wasn't right and then he
got so mad that he broke his hand
on the bar
well he had a bar in his basement and he
just broke his hand over it and i just
felt like that was kind of an
overreaction
uh
you're correct
anytime somebody punches something
because they're so mad
means they're acting like a child my
kids my child does that because they're
a child adults don't do that adults
have self-control and they have
discipline
and they know when to walk away
they don't punch holes in stuff
they don't break their hands on walls
and so
all of this
stemming from
somebody whose body who's not safe in
their own body and they're looking for
somebody else to help them be safe
in that desperation i don't want to be
alone i don't want to be alone and my
feelings are going going going going
going
man that chaos borderline is hard
borderline is hard hard hard hard hard
but there is healing from it it does
take a while but there's healing
but you gotta really really put in the
work
right
yeah
are you worth it
i'm worth it
um i guess
i should just be alone right now and
uh here's the thing i'm not going to
tell you what to do
i'm going to tell you you're worth more
than dating a guy who
lives with his ex-girlfriend
yeah more than that you're worth dating
a guy that you don't think
is cheating on you all the time even if
he's not dude may be incredible dude
maybe stuck in a lease and whatever
probably not but he may be incredible
and
it's making you insane because of the
living arrangements
yeah
and if he won't move then he's saying i
like my living arrangements more than
your well-being
and he's allowed to do that
but you need to hear that for what it is
and exit building left
he talked about like maybe we can rent a
house together instead but he still
wants to keep her as a tenant and i just
feel like that's equivalent of him
saying
like i still want to keep her i want to
i want to keep her somehow
i mean it doesn't sound right
who do you have in your life besides him
that you can sit down and talk talk
about this
um
i'm talking about this as my mom not
your mom not your mom because there's
gonna be some other stuff there with
that and you know that right yeah yes
yeah
um
basically my best friend
who is that
um she's getting married um soon her
name is adrian
do you feel a sense of loss that she's
getting married
um
a little bit yeah
so in that you're gonna mourn that
because she's gonna be signing up to
have somebody else that's her number one
right and that's good and that's but
that's gonna be hard for you
and that may send off your
bpd alarms
right
continue to lever through that okay
that can be hard hard hard i know it's
gonna be hard
and find a counselor that you can work
with and say here's what i've been told
i have diagnostically
and i want to heal from this
and whether it's dbt there's some
there's some really good stuff out there
um that that you can get involved with
that can help with borderline it does
take a while but you can help more
importantly i want you to heal from your
trauma okay i want you to get with a
good trauma counselor in your area
and say i've got to i want to heal from
the sexual assault not that the sexual
assault's ever going to go away but you
will get to a place in healing where
your body won't respond
to every connection moment as though
we're about to be re-traumatized
it can learn to love again and be still
you can feel safe in your own body
that would be really nice
yeah right wouldn't it you know what
you'll be able to do it's so great you
can just go go home from wherever you
are and just lay down and you just go to
sleep can you imagine that
that would be really nice and you have
no interest you don't smoke weed to just
get through a day you don't have to have
18
milligrams of i mean 18 milligrams 180
milligrams of caffeine just to get out
of bed in the morning like you it it's
it's a peaceful
and you he need to hear me say lisa
you're worth that healing this guy might
be it for you it might be
but right now that guy's a major trigger
for you
yeah
and i don't
i'm not a fan of anybody
dating anybody seriously who still lives
with his ex-girlfriend
that's a maturity issue that's a
priorities issue
you're worth more than that lisa
am i telling you go break up i'm just
telling you whoa
and therapists who are listening to this
show for god's sake
i know the cool thing is to be like
whatever you feel is best for you
stop at some point follow a terrier
reels for some point therapist you got
to get involved and you have to say
you're worth more than that
i think you are devaluing yourself
through this relationship or by putting
up with this type of
gaslighting or abuse or whatever the
thing is have some courage therapist to
say that's not a good idea
i know that's not the cool thing
and you just gotta do your own thing and
find out free
at some point you gotta take sides you
gotta help out
be a therapist who cares enough to say
ah that's not that's not smart that's
not serving you well
every time you come in here you sound
more hurt than the last time you were
here and all the hurt seems to be
directed at this one person
is this wise
please please get involved